with hundreds of people
about parenting in the climate crisis.
And I can tell you
that people who are worried about having kids because of climate change
are not motivated by an ascetic pride.
They're nerve-racked.
There's even a movement called BirthStrike,
whose members have declared they're not going to have kids
because of the state of the ecological crisis
and inaction from governments to address this existential threat.
And yes, other generations have also faced their own apocalyptic dangers,
but that is no reason to disregard the very real threat to our survival now.
Some feel that it's better to adopt children.
Or that it's unethical to have more than one,
especially three, four or more,
because kids increase greenhouse gas emissions.
Now, it is a really unfortunate state of affairs
when people who want kids sacrifice their right to
because, somehow, they have been told that their lifestyle choices are to blame
when the fault is far more systemic,
but let's just unpack the logic here.
So an oft-cited study shows that, on average,
having one less child in an industrialized nation
can save about 59 tons of carbon dioxide per year.
While in comparison,
living car-free saves nearly 2.5 tons,
avoiding a transatlantic flight -- and this is just one --
saves about 1.5 tons,
and eating a plant-based diet can save almost one ton per year.
And consider that a Bangladeshi child
only adds 56 metric tons of carbon to their parents' carbon legacy
over their lifetime,
while an American child, in comparison, adds 9,441 to theirs.
So this is why some people argue
that it's parents from nations with huge carbon footprints
who should think the hardest about how many kids they have.
But the decision to have a child and one's feelings about the future
are deeply personal,
and wrapped up in all sorts of cultural norms,
religious beliefs, socioeconomic status, education levels and more.
And so to some, this debate about kids in the climate crisis
can seem like it came from another planet.
Many have more immediate threats to their survival to think about,
like, how they're going to put food on the table,
when they're a single mom working three jobs,
or they're HIV positive or on the move in a migrant caravan.
Tragically, though, climate change is really great at intersectionality.
It multiplies the stresses marginalized communities already face.
A political scientist once said to me that a leading indicator
that climate change is starting to hit home, psychologically,
would be an increase in the rate of informed women
deciding to not have children.
Interesting.
Is it hitting home with you, psychologically?
Are you perhaps someone with climate-linked pre-traumatic stress?
A climate psychiatrist coined that term,
and that's a profession now, by the way, shrinks for climate woes.
They're getting work at a time when some high schoolers
don't want to apply to university any longer,
because they can't foresee a future for themselves.
And this brings me back to my main point.
The growing concern about having kids in the climate crisis
is an urgent indicator of how hard-pressed people are feeling.
Right now, students around the world are screaming for change
in the piercing voice of despair.
And the fact that we can see how we contribute to this problem
that makes us feel unsafe
is crazy-making in itself.
Climate change is all-encompassing
and so are the ways that it messes with our minds.
Many activists will tell you
that the best antidote to grief is activism.
And some psychologists will tell you the answer can be found in therapy.
Others believe the key is to imagine you're on your deathbed,
reflecting back on what's mattered the most in your life,
so you can identify what you should do more of now,
with the time that you have left.
We need all these ideas, and more,
to take care of our innermost selves
as the environments we've known become more punishing towards us.
And whether you have children or not,
we need to be honest about what is happening,
and what we owe one another.
We cannot afford to treat
the psychological impacts of climate change
as some afterthought,
because the other issues, of science, technology and the politics and economy,
feel hard, while this somehow feels soft.
Mental health needs to be an integral part
of any climate change survival strategy,
requiring funding, and ethics of equity and care,
and widespread awareness.
Because even if you're the most emotionally avoidant person on the planet,
there's no rug in the world that's big enough to sweep this up under.
Thank you.
(Applause)